[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's ein superschnelles
weihnachtliches gebäck und zwar mache
ich mal kronen
ich habe auch schon mal kokosmakronen
gemacht und irgendwie andere makronen
auch schon mal wirklich jedenfalls gibt
es heute genau das verlinkt ich euch
jedenfalls gibt es heute mond massiv an
mandl makronen zwischen zum mond mangel
maronen oder monate bei magdeburg wo der
mann hatte beim monaco oder man immer
eine halbe stelle zeigt ich muss zu
arbeiten ja also man kann die wirklich
innerhalb einer halben stunde
superschnell vorbereiten und backen und
dann sind sie fertig und ich will es mir
sagen ich zeige euch gleich die zutaten
und statt ausgleich
ich muss zur arbeit
für die makronen masse brauche ich viel
eiweiß eine prise salz 125 gramm zucker
abrieb von einer unbehandelten zitrone
200 gramm marzipanrohmasse 200 gramm
mandeln 150 gramm gemahlenen bohnen und
hier habe ich noch bei coop laden mit 40
mm durchmesser
den werde ich jetzt gleich noch mal da
ist noch ganz aber falls ihr keine
gewürzmühle oder eine hochleistungs mixa
habt könnt ihr ihn auch ganz einfach
schon gemein kaufen gebe ich zuerst mal
das eiweiß in einer schüssel die
schüssel muss jetzt fettfrei sein das
eiweiß auch komplett frei von eigelb
spuren kein fett mit dabei sonst lässt
es sich nämlich nicht steif schlagen
eine prise salz zum letzten dazu und
jetzt schon mal ein bisschen an
und sobald ich merke dass ich schon
etwas schaurig wird unsere richtung
schnell geht kommt der migration
wird entsteht viel schnee also kommt
jetzt das zucker langsam mit dazu
und dann durch solange weiter bis die b
c masse ganz steigt in der zwischenzeit
kann ich das schon mal die man sonst
einmal und auf dem normalen
[Musik]
jetzt die baiser masse fest kann ich
hier kurz abkratzen
und jetzt werden die restlichen zutaten
nun runter gehoben und bin jetzt keinen
mohn mögt könnt ihr natürlich auch
weglassen und einfach noch mal mehr
mandeln mit dazu geben
aber ich finde nun gibt im gepäck so ein
richtig tolles aroma und passt auch sehr
gut zum marzipan und so ein bisschen
auch mit der zitronenschale verfeinert
ist wirklich ein super toller geschmack
[Musik]
a
jetzt nehme ich einen portionierer da
hat sich bei mir echt bewährten benutzt
jedes jahr zu weihnachten zum backen
oder auch zu an für andere gebäcke und
stehe ich jetzt hier immer eine kleine
menge ab dann kommt die backplane drauf
und die sind jetzt auch richtig hübsche
kleine motive mit drauf und dann kann
ich sie auf dem backblech absetzen
jetzt fragt sich natürlich was mache ich
ohne plätze im portionierer da könnt ihr
zum beispiel auch in kleinen eis
portionierer nehmen aber da klebt die
masse so ein bisschen oder nehmt einfach
zwei löffel formt das ganze so ein
bisschen und setzt es dann auf die
oblate mit den plätzen portionierer geht
es natürlich ein bisschen schneller
[Musik]
die makronen werden jetzt im ofen bei
150 grad umluft für etwa 20 minuten
backen
die makronen zuletzt abgekühlt wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr gerne noch ein
bisschen süß im schnee drüber schreiben
ich finde es sieht immer so winterlich
weihnachtliche aus die zuschauer jetzt
fragen was süßes schnee das ist ein
fuder sogar der nicht schmilzt das heißt
er bleibt ein paar auf dem gehweg liegen
und dann verpacke ich sehe in einer
keksdose ihr wisst ja auch
wahrscheinlich warum es überhaupt
keksdosen gibt zu weihnachten die sind
nämlich dafür dass limburg hat mich alle
auf einmal auf als meine frage ist
wahrscheinlich kommt wie lange halten
die sie machen also wenn ich bedenke
dass sie das demokratisch schon zwei
innerhalb einer minute gegessen hat dann
eine dreiviertel stunde betragen
das einmal kevin allein in new york
anschauen und mit der und danach was man
ehrlich wie daran gehalten schon ein
paar wochen also in dieser luftdichten
keksdose auf jeden fall ein paar wochen
dann verkostete mal und erstmal drin ist
hier seht ihr natürlich hier das formen
ich finde selbstständig gut habe ich
schon gesagt ja schon öfter also
eigentlich jedes mal wenn ich mein
rezept macht sagt er dazu dass er kein
fan ist
aber ich bin seine klassenkameraden
schauen also auch richtig saftig gesagt
maximal üblich über alles auch ganz gut
raus geld ja ich finde es auch sehr gut
ihm vor allem super praktisch also ich
habe wirklich an zeit jetzt nicht lange
gebraucht mit diesem plätzen
portionierer hat es mich insgesamt
vielleicht eine halbe stunde gedauert
hat hat es mich eine halbe stunde
gekostet und ich denke man kann da auch
super einfach die doppelte portion
machen wir mit etwa 63 rausgekommen aber
ihr könnt auch gleich die doppelte
machen und gleich noch die eltern und
schwiegereltern und die ganze familie
mit verlor aber ich glaube es nur 56 ja
wahrscheinlich
deswegen machen wir es mal schluss dass
ich noch ein paar fotos machen kann und
falls ihr dieses rezept gerne nachmachen
wollt geht auch cellestis blog täter
stets noch mal ganz genau für euch und
ich wünsche den fall ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen neben dem morath ist das
blech weg kein yoga und wünsche euch
allen eine schöne vorweihnachtszeit zur
arbeit mitnehmen komik weiter in die
hosentasche stecken kommen noch welche
schätze ich will letztes sein
alle jungs nehmen sagt er möchte lieber
arbeitskollegin gleich bei euch als
ölsamen
[Musik]
euro